this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house greetings you bad [__]
it's Monday January 9th the joint is
brought to you by Draft Kings listen the
NBA playoff picture is locked in and you
know where Uncle Joey's go place for the
Wild Card round action is DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL to kick off the road
to Super Bowl 57. I'll tell you what I'm
gonna do new customers you're gonna bet
five bucks and when your team comes in
you're gonna win 200 and free bets
instantly my picks tonight let me tell
you I love the game PCU against Georgia
tonight for the college championship and
we've got some great playoffs this
weekend plus all new and existing
customers can get a no sweat each day of
the Wild Card round this weekend just
place any NFL bet of your choice if it
loses you'll get a free BET up to ten
dollars with action this good why bet
the NFL playoffs anywhere else and the
casino is on fire too when was the last
time you visited DraftKings casino and
played with a real [__] dealer
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now use promo code Joey new customers
bet five dollars on any NFL team and get
200 and free bets instantly that's code
Joey only at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the NFL
NBA and anybody else you [__] could
dream about minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app today [__] suckers listen
the joint is also brought to you by
liquid IV no matter what your New Year's
goes on foreign
staying hydrated and staying healthy is
bottom for sure liquid IV is the easy
way to stay hydrated you're going to get
five essential vitamins hydrate two
times faster than water alone use it
first thing in the morning like I do
with a little bit of minerals in there
before a workout and on Long flights I
use it in the morning before I go to the
gym I put a little of that arm raw
cholesterol powder in there [__]
tremendous liquid IV is free from gluten
dairy and soy and it contains three
times the electrolytes of traditional
sports drinks grab your liquid IV and
bulk nationwide at Costco or I'm Gonna
Save You 20 off when you shop at liquid
ib.com use code Joey again I'm Gonna
Save You 20 off just go to liquid iv.com
and use code Joey you won't be sorry the
concord grape is tremendous the fruit
bunch is the Menace the Pina Colada
that's 20 off anything with code Joey at
liquid iv.com and the joint is also
brought to you by blue shoe start off
2023 slinging dick Jack blue is here to
make sure you stay hot in the [__]
bedroom all winter long blue shoe is
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
in chewable tablets at the fraction of
the cost just shoot one an empty stomach
and get ready to go Jack forget the
[__] mood glasses listen this [__]
works I love blue shoe they come in
personal little serving pouches you put
them in your pocket and when a victim
pops up who's better than you sign up at
bluetoo.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once you
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all online
no visits to the doctor's office no brow
beating no nothing blue true tablets are
made in the USA and the Sheep ship the
screen greatly you could perform with
extra confidence when it's time to get
down Bluetooth can help try Bluetooth
free when using promo code Joey j-o-e-y
just pay a fin five dollars for shipping
bluetooth.com code Joey for your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
important safety information thanks to
Bluetooth for sponsoring The Joint let's
get this party started it's Monday we
ain't got time to [__] around
foreign
[Music]
sup you bad [__] it's Monday
the 9th of [__] January the
first week of the year is in the [__]
books I had a great [__] week I mean
we all did I mean listen nothing
happened I mean nothing [__] happened
people were asleep till Thursday some
people woke up out of that coma on
Friday but all in all
it was a [__] great week I mean it
started out with that Monday night game
I I don't even know what the [__]
happened I was watching an episode of uh
of uh Yellowstone I've been watching
Yellowstone for the last couple months
that's like the [__] soprano rednecks
they don't [__] around up there dog and
uh I was just watching it I bet the game
I had a small bet on Cincinnati I love
the under you know and I and it was
funny because Rich Voss had called me
and he's like I like the over
and you know I was kind of cheering for
him I bet the end it was 25 bucks I
wasn't gonna it wasn't gonna make me or
break me but I I figured I always
watched the game from halftime on I
watched like the last quarter on Monday
night me and my wife watched something
else maybe my daughter comes down we
watch some other [__]
and I'm looking at the score and it's
stuck on 73 and I'm like [__] poor Rich
Voss this under is coming in like a
[__] you know because if you go
on DraftKings right on the front page
just open it up to check the score and
it'll tell you ten to three it's a
Monday night game whatever the [__] it
was
and after a while the episode ended and
I put on uh I invited a buddy of my Noah
from Buffalo he lives around the corner
and I go you want to come on watch the
game and he texts me and he's like hey
it would have been weird for me to be
over there right now with this [__]
happening can you believe what's
happening I didn't know what he was
talking about I'm like ah okay I'm
watching Yellowstone so when Yellowstone
ended I [__] put the game on when my
wife went up and I saw everybody
meal around the guy and praying and what
was going on it was very sad I'm happy
they stopped the game you know it's uh
rough when you see something like that
and then the [__] [__] started I
mean it was uh people were fighting on
TV shows over it and
you know the the [__] covet and uh
about the vaccine you know people were
going off about vaccine and the
anti-vaxxas he got hit hard in the chest
and it's uh well the really crazy world
guys nothing could just happen anymore
nobody could just slip on the [__]
floor did you ever notice that nobody
could slip nobody could just slip on a
banana peel get up put a Mercury Chrome
on that [__] knee and go the [__]
home it's like he slipped because there
was a conspiracy you know I mean it was
a [__] tremendous week last week I
mean uh people going out against Dana
White for smacking his wife [__]
people were going off you know I even
put I this is the funniest thing in the
world listen I got nothing against Dana
I love [__] Dana Dana's been very
good to me over the years whenever he
sees me gives me a big hug and the whole
thing it's the last thing the UFC needed
you know by Dana smacking somebody I
don't know what happened neither do you
I don't know what happened near to you
you know his wife smacked them it was
like a [__] canned reaction and
people going off and a lot of people
calling for more more needs to be done
about this you know and it's like
listen man you know it's done it's time
to move on what could Dana do maybe
raise awareness on it
and uh help the UFC like make the rules
a little tougher but there's to show
people [__] happens all the time and
[__] happens all the time when you're
drinking
that's why I'm very happy that my wife
and I don't drink together I've had one
girlfriend that I used to party with and
it never worked it never worked for me
it really was a nightmare that was one
of the worst relationships she's a great
lady I still talk to I Love The Debt
but it was one of the worst
relationships I was ever involved in
because she drank heavily I snorted and
when she drank she did Coke and when I
snorted I drank so now here we are
stuck in a room yelling at each other
you know and uh this is why I don't like
alcohol guys when it comes to all that
[__] and listen man Dana made a mistake
he owned up to it
which is more than half these [__]
people walking around and doing we don't
know what happened we weren't there
you know it's like I tell you people you
can't go anywhere no more because what a
coincidence if somebody had a camera on
them
put out a statement and the whole thing
and that that helps but the damage has
been done it's a video listen man I
respect Dana for [__] uh
you know stepping up the way he did most
men would have ran away with it most
people would have ran away from it I'm
sorry
Dana stepped up he said the truth is
what happened and it won't happen again
and now
but like you have these agitators that
are like you know get rid of them fire
them do this do that you know we've in
today's world we've forgotten that we're
human anymore
this world culture has this that we're
not human we're not allowed to make
mistakes no more what used to be a
little [__] mistake like just a
little mistake like a DUI
a d listen it happens I'm not the king
of you know how I feel about these
[__] things but even a DUI happens
you don't know what what happened you
had one too many Gins you didn't [__]
weigh yourself you didn't know it was
gonna stay in your system and it happens
now you have to think about why it
happened and Manning up to it you know
it's the people go well I didn't even
drink I've never drink in 12 hours well
you Rick like a [__] Gin Mill so what
the [__] are we talking about it you
know we're living in a world today that
it's nobody's fault
and even if it is their fault they don't
want to [__] come up and go this is
what happened this is why it [__]
happened
and most importantly
then it won't happen again
that's the most important thing liquid
IV Never Killed Nobody [__] a
little fruit punch flame and one package
and the [__] thing Zoom I'm ready to
go I'm filled with sodium my cells get
to eat I don't give a [__] anymore guys
but yeah this shit's got to stop where
uh
now we have snitch snitches like hey man
we have to prosecute him if it was a
black man listen
it's all how you react to things
and uh
for Dana White you know what I I made a
joke on Monday on Tuesday I was like I'm
coming up smacking [__] like Dana
White or smacking people I didn't say
[__] I didn't say a woman I didn't say
anything again guys
it's a joke
it's a joke and a couple people hit me
up on the side that's pretty douchey
this would never happen 10 years ago 10
years ago I used to always make little
jokes like that and people go hilarious
whatever we all knew was a [__] joke
now it's like Joey what the [__] your
insult I didn't insult anybody but the
good thing out of it I woke up Wednesday
and Elon Musk was following me on
Twitter so I must have said something
[__] him right you know so guys it's uh
just copy your [__] anymore who gives a
[__] they can't [__] judge you but
this won't culture everything is a
[__] mistake now you say something
wrong on whatever it's a mistake and
it's not just a mistake like it used to
be it's like the end of the [__]
world I had to stop reading like Yahoo
page Yahoo is the [__] white people
drive me crazy Paige they put [__] on
there that I don't even know why they
put a [__] on there they're talking
about [__] that has nothing to do with
you and you have to look at and go
what's this got to do with me if I hear
about the January 6th [__] thing one
more time what the [__] guys what the
[__]
you know that comparing uh
I even saw comparisons of Dana White to
Will Smith
like a year later like Jesus Christ like
don't you have anything better to do
than to think about what happened a year
ago with Will Smith now they're trying
to bring that [__] smack back in
comparison it was just a bad [__] New
Year's Eve for a lot of people look at
the other UFC fighter Phil Barone
[__] killed his girlfriend
in Mexico that guy's gonna rot under the
[__] jail in Mexico
you know again we weren't there we don't
know what happened it was an argument
she cheated on him and told them on
vacation why would you tell a [__]
guy that's crazy that you cheat on him
on vacation he slammed her in the shower
whatever the [__] happened you know I
didn't read the whole thing just uh
somebody was telling me the other day
and I think the most disturbing thing
that is on everybody's mind is again is
the Delia thing
guys his friend I have not been around
that crew
uh in two and a half years
you know I did not know what happened I
was not on that tour I was not I'm just
hearing about uh documentary and [__]
and uh I'm hearing about
tour [__] managers and girls and
you know guys I got a 10 year old I
don't know what the [__] to tell you
anymore
when I was leaving it away I was leaving
in a way not to move but I did it to
shut a chapter in my life
and move on to the next chapter
what I saw
before I left and it wasn't anything to
do with sex of girls it was just a
common attitude and what had happened to
comedians in general
that I knew this wasn't going to get any
better it wasn't the pandemic it wasn't
Netflix it wasn't anything it was just
things had changed in the world of
Comedy when I moved to Los Angeles
a comedian you know toured 20 weeks he
shot a show 20 weeks and he lived his
life the other 20 weeks you toured
around Los Angeles you did the improvs
you did well back before I started you
did igbies and the ice house and all
these other things and then the game
changed the game changed and it was more
about it wasn't about the brick wall and
the microphone no more it was about
200 here
300C clubs and 400 C clubs and 600 c
clubs and 700c clubs and people trying
to exploit it from every way they could
and I understand things grow things are
supposed to [__] uh evolve
but it wasn't about the uh
wasn't about the quality anymore
I mean people shoot specials every
[__] year and as a comic and as a
comedy fan and as a comedy [__]
whatever the [__] you might want to call
me anybody knows that's why I love uh
the white dude that used to uh
Anthony
Jeselnik I'm a big fan of Anthony
jesling
because Anthony Anthony jesner could run
a material in a comedy club for a year
then he moves on to a theater for a year
then he shoots a special he's not
worried about that check
most people would take 33 years would
shoot two specials Anthony jeselnick
cares he shoots one special for that I
applaud him
but it what I'm talking about here we
just wasn't about
me at the comedy store getting my dick
sucked in 1997. it became
something bigger than that on all fronts
you know the podcast scene came in that
blew up people you know uh I benefited a
lot from the podcast scene because it
was it went right back to where I'm one
of my strong points which is [__]
storytelling you know so you can only
[__] podcasts you tell stories it's
the pathway to [__] uh you know
people really admiring you for whatever
the [__] you do whatever stupid stories
I said you know we had the podcast to
that listen guys
let's be honest
if you work the road like any of these
guys you have enough money that's a
great comedy living you add a podcast to
it it becomes even a greater podcast
living
now you say to yourself
how can I balance all this how can I
balance all this how can I balance the
comedy the podcasting the writing the
lifting my family my wife you know how
can I balance all this and if you really
want like I did two podcasts a week and
I did every other weekend down the road
okay
when I say every other weekend it's four
[__] shows a weekend two in one
theater to another theater
and you're out there [__] banging it
every week regardless and now remember
the weeks I'm off the weeks I'm not on
the road doesn't mean I'm home Fanning
my balls with some guy feeding me
[__] coconut chips no I'm doing
Tuesday at the store not one show two
shows Thursday at the show two shows
maybe even three an original room a
ballet room a main room and maybe a 10
o'clock main room
I wouldn't go out on Fridays Fridays
just for my family and I went out on
[__] Saturday nights to the Ice House
the story we did the 9 30 spot and
whenever anybody else called me with
people always call you with something
hey I got this room this guy canceled
can you stop by and do 10 minutes so I
was always [__] moving
after a while you're like okay what
needs to be done here okay I'm not
seeing my wife enough
she's bitching I'm not seeing my
daughter enough she's bitching you know
I've gained 13 pounds I'm not working
out but my bank account is okay
and I'm having fun on the podcast
I'm doing all these things but you look
and you see what's my income and what's
it causing to my family I mean what's it
the damage doing to me I'm a big [__]
reader and I'm excited about 2023
because I started reading again you know
I lost a little contact by not being on
the road and on planes I stopped reading
I loved reading on a plane there's
nothing better than you know I love
preparing to [__] read like getting
in a corner and smoking a bong hit and
maybe getting a [__] Coke Zero and
putting ice cubes in it and knowing I'm
not gonna move for an hour and a half if
I move
to [__] take three more hits off that
[__] joint that's the only reason I'm
moving you know you get so enthused
about reading and I read for years I
read about rock bands you know from Guns
and Roses to Aerosmith to [__] and
when they got Nirvana and when they got
off the road basically they hated each
other
they hate each other and then they went
away for a year and wrote and played
with the kid and smoke some different
dope and then they came back and they
all loved each other again and they were
creatively creatively ready to pursue
the next album it's great to read books
about rock stars
and like we all have uh you know Mike
likes Nirvana but if I pull Mike aside
I'll go hey Nirvana album you didn't
like Mike and he'll go wow this one
album had this or whatever didn't happen
and then years later you read about it
and you'll read out the record label was
forcing them to make that out more they
for [__] uh going at him for not
putting like they want a ballad the only
reason why we made that stupid song is
because the record label kept asking for
a [__] ballot we don't do [__]
ballots you know
so I read all this [__] about all these
bands and how they would come home and
how Aerosmith they hated each other so
much they lived in a house and didn't
talk to each other when they made rocks
they would have to sign a list to go to
the studio so they didn't see one
another they ended up being the best
band in the [__] world you know one
of the best bands in the [__] world
but there's a balance
in L.A they didn't want Comics to have
balance no more all that was forgotten
you could tell your agent 10 times my
daughter's birthday is January 8th
they kept calling you the light you
[__] what about the seventh what can
you do tonight how about you leave early
on the eighth what time is my party well
do the party at five so you can leave by
seven and be on stage by eight and
you're like
what the [__] are you [__]
talking about
so there was no bounce anymore
guys what do you think was gonna [__]
happen
what the [__] do you think was gonna
happen and there's no TV for these guys
why because TV don't pay
come on man how can I expect Bert Tom
Lewis Gomez Ari to do a sitcom when
you know what if they go on the road one
weekend
they make more money
than working 10 days on that [__]
sitcom
that's kind of [__] scary if I come
to you and go hey I'm gonna pay you 5
000 bucks for 10 days you're gonna shoot
a movie that's 500 a day whatever 6 000
for 10 days can I come to you and I go
listen I'm gonna give you five grand for
two days and pay for your plane ticket
and pay for your meals and you're gonna
drink and somebody's gonna suck your
dick and you know you'd have to go to
costume with table reads or what would
you rather do and you're like okay maybe
it's a movie with somebody special that
you've always wanted to work with all
right I'm in but unless no
so these guys will take these Road gigs
because think about it these movies
don't [__] pay you you know it's Tom
Papa who talked me into doing the money
Saints in Newark because he told me when
he did the [__] Liberace movie he
broke even
how the [__] do you break even on a
[__] movie that sad [__]
commentary
that you went to acting class or your
[__] life you joined plays you took
[__] from [__] immigrant [__]
casting people and immigrant producers
you don't know what they're saying and
now they want to pay you you know how
the [__] is it that they wouldn't give
me a [__] plane ticket The Grudge
Match
it's a dinero movie with Kevin Hart and
I'm not mad I'm not saying nothing
derogatory about De Niro Stallone or
[__] Kevin Hart but how do I not have
a [__] plane ticket
so you think about all these things
these guys they're forcing you to be not
Road comics but Road Savages at 50 you
should be honest on a CBS show
you know what I'm saying like that was
the original plan for a lot of these
guys so but no
it's completely different then they put
pressure on you because that flicks
won't give everybody a [__] special
and they won't give you a reason or a
rhyme so you're walking around going why
is this guy got a special why don't I
have a [__] special HBO started to
wake up now with HBO Max but they're not
paying on these [__] specials
supposedly so it's like
you
that's tough and I'm not whining I'm not
the type of [__] that'll whine
but now looking back at my last four
years of doing stand-up in L.A they
weren't Pleasant at all they weren't
Pleasant I did it because I I was
responsible and I wanted to make people
laugh and I wanted to have a good time
but it wasn't my [__]
be-all end-all I knew something wasn't
[__] right I just kept doing it but
I'm like why am I working this hard
why am I doing all these things when I
have a child and a kid and I kept
telling these agents hey man you gotta
[__] stop killing these [__] guys
you people are killing these Comics
single-handedly you're gonna [__]
kill them how do I know because I see
them I see them at the road I see them
at airports
but we become as a
and listen I say we because I did the
same thing you start accepting things
that you were never accepted before
but you're like you know what ah [__] it
what can I do I'm sick of arguing I'm
sick of raising my [__] hand I'm sick
of everything
I wasn't in a great position
when I [__] left Los Angeles and I
repeated it three thousand times my head
was up my ass [__] was happening at the
end the last eight months that was just
unexplainable they were just
unexplainable
and then one day the walls came coming
down and all these allegations of
different people and and it was like
that hasn't hasn't this not been
suspicious to anybody how all these
allegations came out against everybody
all at once
yeah like all these allegations came out
all at once you know and listen I don't
know what's true I don't know what's not
true I know the ones I was involved in
was just [__] a smoke screen and
[__] to the point where they reached
out to Bill Byrne said listen tell Joey
we we won't say anything about him no
more if his people stop attacking us on
Twitter yeah this is what to tell you
people they didn't even know what the
[__] they were fighting for
crystallize got seriously problems uh I
know they [__] were going to protest
the show last week
I know that they banned them I did not
know if he ended up doing the weekend in
San Diego I'm out of the loop so I don't
know what's going on but
I heard he entered a rehab for uh sex
addiction or something
one of the Articles had it on there and
I really don't know what to say like if
somebody called me right now what did
you see what the hell I didn't see any
of this guys I saw girls come to these
shows and none of them had a [__] mum
on and none of them were handcuffed and
you know none of them were I didn't say
they were all there on on voluntary
bases what I'm trying to say so
I don't know what's going on
um
when I got out of the loop I got out of
the [__] Loop and I'm very happy I
don't look back I love those guys I love
them all
but if you guys know anything about me
that's not what I got into comedy for to
cause all that problem to go to war with
all these guys yeah and I'm not going to
say I haven't had problems with comics
in the past because I have I did it for
30 years you're gonna have a problem
with a couple guys whatever but then I
gotta roll over to YouTube
I don't want him to roll over to [__]
my personal life and then everything I
do on my podcast is about that you know
for the last couple of years I don't
know what's going on the internet
it's not fun anymore you know it's not
fun anymore when
you know years ago I would post
something that had no value to it just a
stupid throwaway joke
and I mean the last couple years people
question it
it's either one joke or two jokes or you
know they didn't like how you said it or
it's too early I think I said some a
couple weeks ago oh it's too early go
[__] yourself you don't know whatever
leave that [__] up to me
I'm the comic you paint houses I don't
[__] come to you
I'm gonna tell you about not put that
[__] trimming on there or whatever
leave the timing up to me I love [__]
bad timing I'm the king of bad timing
the only guy by the way guys if you guys
got a chance do me a big favor
how about a big prayer for Dean Delray
and his family man he lost his mom last
week and I've been talking to him every
day nothing nothing bothers me more
then when somebody loses mom nobody and
I've been telling you this [__]
for 11 years since I got on the podcast
the other night I woke up in the middle
of night and I just checked the
Instagram and I saw that his mother had
passed and guys I couldn't even sleep
the rest of the [__] night like
because I know Dean
I know Dean and I know what his mother
meant to him and I thought he was in LA
so I got up the next day early and I
[__] I knew at 1201 I was going to
have a phone into Dean I called him like
11 30 just to see and he was in Florida
and I felt a lot better I got to talk to
him so he'll be in Florida for the next
couple weeks uh you know he lost the
payment at the beginning of the [__]
year what a way to start a [__] here
so if you find it anyway in your heart
you know light a candle from say a
prayer send them something you know yeah
candles lit say something to them he'll
appreciate all of it man and uh he got a
cremate it you know I would have sent
flowers
gone down to the CD the good thing about
Dean is he's doing the last show with me
at the [__] Sony theater on the 29th
he's coming up so I told him your family
when you clean up all that mess down
there shoot up straight here let's hang
out for a few days Leo come Michael come
and uh we'll have a [__] Dynamite
time
yeah
I had a great [__] weekend this
weekend
not jumping up and down weekend type
like you know
I got my dick sucked right two Quaaludes
it was a very different [__] grateful
weekend you know
I thought that by me getting older I was
going to turn 60 that I'd be more
concerned with me turning 60 I'd be
depressed I'd have to talk to a
therapist or and I tell you guys it
hasn't been anything like that like the
uh the countdown I haven't even really
thought about it it's just
it's just a number you know for me I'm
not even uh I feel great you know I'm
not in pain anywhere my knees feel
better
um
like I said last week this last week I
had one of the best weeks of my life
because
guys listen I've done a lot of bad
things but I've done a lot of good
things things that should have made me
feel really good about what I was doing
and I did for the time being you know
you book a [__] many Saints anything
is is
when you're an Entertainer a performer
you know when you when you get off stage
and you have a great set
you're really grateful you're like wow I
can't believe I [__] did that or
whatever
uh
last week I went to jiu jitsu twice uh
blue belt class
I've been going to that place for uh
maybe 15 months now
and I've been eligible to go to Blue
Bell class for maybe six months now
maybe seven months
and every week I always catch a core
class I'll catch a blue class and maybe
two fundamental classes which are like
drilling classes
and I can live with that you know but
something always bothered me I'm like
though I can't make two blue classes you
know I'm getting too old the blue
classes are a little you know who's ever
teach them they're a little deeper you
do a little bit of rolling you do a live
a lot of live rolling like starting from
back or starting from the turtle or
starting from side control and there's a
lot of movement you drill a lot you know
so you go up to burn over 500 calories
you know what I'm saying you'll [__]
burn it 600 700
and usually if I do it Tuesday I'm dead
till [__] Friday like it's over Joey
like you're in no danger I'll catch the
class Friday so I'll go Monday Tuesday
and Friday
and sometimes I go Tuesday
sometimes I go Monday and I'll [__]
around in Monday class and I'll get sore
and then I won't be back till Thursday
and then I finish off the class strong
with Friday so I never really do two
blue belt classes last week I did two
blue bug classes
and I got to tell you something I felt
more proud of that than [__] doing a
Netflix special yeah like I I was like
was I this happy when I did my Netflix
bicycle another special full of
scotchods no this makes me [__] happy
like I was [__] walking on air for
two days like I went to two blue belt
classes this week good for Uncle [__]
Joey yeah you know and I'm telling
people like on the patreon podcast I
told people
that is the little things
you know like I see all these motivation
[__] on Instagram and these guys are
showing you watches with 20 million
pieces of Diamonds and they're showing
you driving up to a [__] plane and
they're telling you you're dead if you
don't do this and [__]
you know but and so now it leaves you
going well nothing really happens big in
my life until I get a watch with that
email and [__] diamonds on it or
nothing's gonna happen unless I fly in a
private Jane I I'm flying in a private
plane smoking a cigar eating [__]
food by myself showing you how important
I am that's what I told you about before
like that whole thing that was going on
with Tom you know that people like I
know for me I would feel insecure if I'm
trying to make striving and you're
showing me [__] pictures of a watch
with 28 [__] diamonds in my world
when I was 20 22 25 I'd be insecure when
I'm 35 I'm like yeah that's what I get
I'm a piece of [__] for that [__]
working and uh this is what I get you
know but nobody ever tells you about the
little accomplishments how you get
to being grateful for that [__] watch
or how you're grateful for sitting in
the back of a private plane with a cigar
and telling your story to people whoever
gives a [__] you know but it starts with
little things guys it doesn't start with
[__] eighty thousand dollar watch
like this is my watch this is what you
should be working for no you should be
working for the little things
I thought of this last week like how
happy I felt on Friday I couldn't even
tell my wife like you don't understand I
did two blue ball classes this week like
I was just so grateful but I am I was
grateful but at the same time I'm like
this is what I've been saying for years
Little Steps become big steps
that's it
took me a [__] year to do hey it
might take you six months Joey's a loser
but I did it
and next week I might do two blue belt
classes and a core class
and the week after that I might do two
Blue Bell classes and a black belt class
but I'm on my way
and people don't celebrate the little
[__] things man
I swear to God because we live in such a
pressure [__] world anymore like you
gotta drive a Maserati and you got to
have a blonde with fake tits and you
gotta be able to smoke a cigar in the
back of a private plane and and when
they tell you these things they they
tell you in the condescending type of
way to make even feel worse and I look
at this and I'm like these people no
wonder we're [__] crazy because we
don't even know how to celebrate the
little [__] things anymore
everything's got to be a Maserati how
are you going to go from driving your
[__] bicycle on Martin Luther King
Boulevard to drive in a Maserati can
somebody please [__] tell me that
unless somebody leaves you a lottery
ticket with 18 billion dollars it's
basically impossible you're gonna have
to take little [__] steps along the
way maybe a a Hugo or a [__] uh
what's those electric cars those Prius
is there's got to be something no you're
not going to go from a [__]
skateboard right to a Goddamn Maserati
so that's why I was looking at that and
I was looking what happened to me last
week and I'm like
this is what happens to people this is
why people aren't satisfied in their
lives because they're waiting for the
big ship to come and they never
celebrate the little crab boat
that might show up and give you a piece
of sushi you're like ah he showed up and
he just gave me a piece of sushi who
also giving me a [__] piece of sushi
it's like I tell my wife whenever I go
like we get any checks today she's like
hey you gotta check for a dollar 39. I
go who sent you a check today [__]
nobody sent you a [__] Jake but I
gotta check for a dollar 39. that's a
lot better than anybody else is doing
for anybody ain't that a [__]
yeah it was [__] great man I can't
believe I got to do it at 60. you know
so [__] it the sky is the limit age is
just a [__] number
and you got to go to for better yourself
everybody would think by now I'd be
saying well I'm gonna go into an arena
and
I got no interest for any of that [__]
that [__] the [__] self
another thing that happened last week
was my daughter turned 10.
my daughter's birthday was officially
yesterday the 8th of uh January
the reason why I gave you that [__]
here beating about turning 60s because I
thought I'd be concerned
with turning 60 like a home but I'm 50
days away from turning 60 this and this
and this that's what I have been
thinking about I'm like that's what I'm
going to concern myself with until about
midweek until about Wednesday and I'm
like holy [__]
Mercy is going to be 10 years old
and I thought about a conversation my
wife and I had
when we started dating and I thought
about a conversation no not even a
conversation I thought about what I was
thinking
and I remember my wife and I having a
talk one night
she had a couple cocktails in it
I'd had a couple lines of Coke in me I
remember we're trying to talk
but I kept looking at the bottom of the
door because I was paranoid I kept
seeing somebody walked by the [__]
the door thing I'll never forget this
night and she was
telling me concerns of her
thinking she wouldn't be able to have a
child again we weren't even talking
about us having children we were just
talking about we had just met we've been
together 10 months nobody's going to
want to Advocate with me after 10 months
or nothing
we were just talking about concerns and
she was telling me that she just didn't
think
it was ever going to happen for you know
her childhood where she was from
and I remember telling her like this is
what happened to me you know
I failed I said that I [__] failed I
failed you know and uh
so I have no [__] interest
I have no interest
the only interest I have with kids if
Mike wants to bring his kid over to
watch a football game or watching a play
shoot pool I had no interest for a child
so I committed to Comedy and
she committed to her [__] life and
somewhere along the line we met in the
middle
and uh
I got my [__] together I stopped doing
drugs and I [__] uh proposed to her
and then I don't know
four years later she came up [__]
pregnant and again I had my doubts
I knew who I was and I knew what I had
done before
and uh
when she told us she was pregnant
between me and you guys I gave myself a
year with him I'm like
after she has the child I'll probably
I'll probably uh
should keep everybody here to realize
what everybody else in my life has
realized that
I'm damaged goods I'm not going to be
any good for this child
this is not going to be any good for me
and it's really not going to be good for
you and I remember being her being about
seven months and we were at a place
called The Habit
it's like a cheeseburger joint not the
best cheeseburgers it was the only thing
we had in Studio City they had like a
nice chicken sandwich or something
we were over there eat one day and she
was explaining to me
you know about her child and all this
and I'm like listen I'm gonna tell you
something
I'm gonna give you money for the kid
I love you to death I'm gonna love this
kid but I can't tell you my involvement
with this child I'm all in one you know
like I wish I was
I have a folder
of the reasons why I wasn't going to be
a good dad even a good human being or
even a [__] good father like I did I
have a folder of things telling me why
like not that I wrote down Mike saying
you're a loser but I like to have
paperwork from courts I have paperwork
from judges I have paperwork from
prisons I got paperwork out the ass
telling me
that I would never even make it to be a
good [__] man you know I had my
doubts over the years and listen when I
met Terry I didn't know what direction
my life was going to be and I was just
going to [__] stick it out with her
until like I said she realized what
everybody else realized that I had
nothing going on for me and nothing was
ever gonna come out for me and uh
you know we put our heads down and
I cleaned up my act a little bit again
not not even like you thought I was at
home going I'm cleaning up my hack
because I want to have a kid you're out
of your mind I was just cleaning up my
Act
so I wouldn't die I didn't want to die
like [__] I didn't want to die in no
D I didn't want to [__] die with Coke
in my nose I just didn't want I wanted
to give myself a fair [__] chance at
this [__] world
and uh I did and also one day she came
to me she was pregnant I'm like good
luck
good luck here we go what's that [__]
Def Leppard song Bringing on the
heartache here we go
this is not going to work for everybody
involved and
[__] Sunday yesterday was the 10th
birthday
I think I grabbed my wife like Thursday
I'm like can I talk to you
like at night after Mercy went to sleep
and I just reminded of all this [__]
and I go this birthday is so [__]
important
this this is the most important thing
I've ever done in my life this 10th
birthday
and then it dawned on me you ever have
like your own birthday and you see like
you have like a grandmother or mom who's
more excited about your birthday than
you are you ever have that like your dad
or something we're so excited for your
birthday you're like whatever
you know it's just a [__] birthday
I'm just turning 17. oh you're excited
about is that gift card all that [__]
hundred dollar bill that Grandma puts in
the thing you don't give a [__] now I
realized
now I realized why your parents get so
excited on your birthdays now I realized
and for me I was really [__] like
this was a feather in my [__] cap
[__]
this is this is I'm telling you guys
like I didn't even dawn on this I had
not been thinking about this this never
even crossed my [__] mind
till this past goddamn week though I was
like
this little girl has been in my life for
10 years
on my standards I've been a model
citizen in those 10 [__] years
on my standards I'm who I was before and
who I am now I have been a model [__]
citizen when I got here I realized that
me leaving at night like I gotta go do a
show that was not gonna work anymore
that was not gonna work anymore I she
wanted me to be a [__] dad
that [__] was not gonna work no more she
told me this
the New Year's before the pandemic 2020
was the pandemic that's when she pulled
me aside New Year's Eve we were in
Huntington Beach
and she's like my [__] aunt was here
this weekend and you were only with her
for like an hour
she goes I know it was heavy on Mom you
got to be around more and I was like you
know what man
she ain't lying and if you saw my
schedule for the pandemic that year I
didn't have a lot of work
I had one week a month until July
or June or something like that and then
September I was picking it up but I
hadn't even booked the week out yet the
year up I think the only thing I had in
the fall was Parks Casino
like I had this year I was slowing it
down already
the pandemic just speeded it made me
think about what I really wanted to do
in my life
and I cannot [__] believe
I'm a parent for 10 years now
I'd [__] failed as a parent guys I
[__] failed
and when I realized I didn't really fail
like the way I'm saying it
but I didn't have a chance I was not
going to be the parent that I wanted to
be that we're never going to allow that
and I was too hard-headed to accept any
other way so I said you know what
[__] you [__] I'm not doing
this and now she's going to be 33 in
three weeks and we haven't seen each
other in close to over 20 [__] years
but this is what happened and I was just
going to lay down and take this losses
it's never going to work again thank God
thank God I got another chance
even though I was [__] petrified of
that goddamn chance and I wrapped my
[__] arms around it and here we are
and she's a happy little [__] girl
she's got a way better life at 10 than
my wife and I had at 10 o'clock I was
damaged
[__] Goods do you understand me that
at 10 years old I was damaged [__]
Goods the story about the nun that
happened when I was 10. my daughter is
so far away from Ever Lifting her hand
to a [__] nun or anybody it is just
delicious
it has been a real honor to see this and
it has been a real honor for me to be a
part of this [__] if you guys think I
give a [__] about who's doing because
who's doing theaters or who's involved
in a [__] child porn thing you know
all this [__] you people are [__]
crazy that's the last thing I want to
hear about I don't know what's going on
out there anymore half those guys don't
even talk to me anymore and it's okay I
talked to Tom this last week I talked to
Bert from time to time Theo checks in
with me from time to time Ari's my
[__] brother Duncan's my brother Red
Man's my brother Joe's my brother beside
that I really couldn't tell you what the
[__] is going on I talked to Eleanor
from time to time I talked to Josh Wolf
I talked to my man Ryan seckler
that's it guys I don't know what's going
on out there I don't hear from those
guys I know they're [__] uh
Theo is in war with Brendan and Bobby
Lee is in war with Brendan and I just
saw somebody else's at war with Brendan
I don't know anything about that and
that's not why I got into this business
and not any of this I just want my
little Nook here in [__] New Jersey
where I get to come up here with twice a
week and [__] with you [__] and
bust your jokes maybe tell you a story
that you get something from or that you
maybe don't get something from makes no
difference to me anymore guys I'm just
trying to have a good [__] time I'm
turning 60. I'm an old [__] man with
a big dick and a new [__] heart and
uh that's it and that's that man I'm
just excited on Little Things anymore 10
[__] years I've been a parent I was
told I couldn't [__] make it doing
anything and here I'm a parent for 10
[__] years
guys don't believe what they tell you do
not believe anything this has turned out
to be a [__] wonderful Journey for me
regardless of what happened early on
regardless of that [__] who cares that's
gone that's never gonna happen again I
mean people are going to [__] come
and go
but I'm never going to be put in that
position again I don't even care about
half that [__] anymore
[__] it it's 2023 [__] time to
learn and do new [__] things and I
tell you you can hear this from me if
you thought something wasn't going to
pan out for you now give it a second
shot
just because you quit the first time
doesn't mean you really quit you just
took some time off to look at it the
right way because you know the ad you
needed when I got into comedy in 91 I
always tell people yeah I did comedy
from 91 but it was 93 when I really got
a grasp on what I had to do
am I was it a waste of time that I did
comedy for two years
kind of sort of because I was doing it
all wrong but I would have never learned
to do it right if I wasn't involved in
those two years
you know my gave me a guitar two years
ago
played that a teacher on Zoom it just
didn't work for me on Zoom there was two
things that turned me off about playing
the guitar the zoom lessons and
everybody's telling me about my thumb
every time I get a guitar player from
Rudy he would yell at me or one of my
friends would help me with a lesson they
would always tell me about my thumb that
my thumb stick that and then I look at
[__] slash and his thumb is sticking
out I look at whatever I see that that
thumb is sticking out I understand when
you learn something that
they teach it for you so you don't pick
up bad habits maybe showing your thumb
is a bad habit
I got a little down on the guitar and I
didn't touch it for like four [__]
months
and the whole time I was like wait a
second it's not that I can't play the
guitar I gotta figure out how I could
play it learn something attack it
so I talked to a guy about three weeks
ago you know before the holidays and I
was like hey man I like to do guitar
lessons and we talk things I just don't
want them on Zoom
you know but then that sucks is that I
gotta actually pick the guitar up put it
in the [__] thing packed my little
speaker and take it somewhere else and
that's a [__] nightmare because I
don't want to break the thing I don't
want to hurt it you know
so now I'm ready so I'm gonna start
lessons with him in two weeks
did I quit the guitar no not at all I
just took a break to see how to do it
to work for me you know a couple years
ago I ripped my [__] hamstring I
thought I was done with jiu-jitsu I was
like you know what I was never really
that good at it
I was never really that good at it and
I'm older and now the thing but those
two years I didn't train I kept thinking
to myself [__]
if I could do it again this is how I
would do it
needed to do it I saw on Instagram I saw
an interviewer Roger Gracie
and he was talking about that people go
to Jujitsu in their mind they're going
to get tougher
and that's not what you have to try and
focus on you have to focus on going to
get better
so I was going to Jujitsu all these
times a week and thinking I was doing it
right now
I went back now and now I'm training it
better
I'm not going for quantity anymore I'm
going for quality
so if you tried something and it didn't
work for you at one time whether it's
selling [__] balloons at the carnival
and you came home and after six months
you're like I could have been a good
[__] balloon salesman I just didn't
[__] do it the right way I didn't
attack it the right way and this has
happened to me for years that I didn't
attack something the right way and
you're like what why would I quit that
you know I I suffered a lot from
quitting basketball when I did as a kid
till this day if I had a second chance
of not quitting I would have [__]
stuck without if I could turn the clocks
back I would just focus on basketball
now even if I was going to end up being
five for ten it didn't it didn't matter
it didn't matter but when I was getting
old I was like look at my mother my
mother's a half a [__] my father's six
foot four I look at my uncles they're
all six foot one I'm in no danger of
being a [__] College forward so I
lost in my mind Sun Tzu most battles
fought before that one most battles are
won before their foot
so do you see where I'm going with this
sometimes man it's just your mental
preparation for some so it's 20 23 you
gotta you got a [__] chance to be a
[__] killer this year
maybe you have a chance of being a
killer it's something that you thought
you failed that and you failed at it not
because you failed at it you just felt
you failed at it because you didn't
attack it the right way and trust me
guys when I got into comedy I thought I
was attacking it the right way it took
me two [__] maybe three years to
realize that I wasn't
I didn't panic I picked up the [__]
new notebook I got back to my Judy Brown
book and I asserted the [__] things I
had learned and guess what by [__] 95
that was a completely different comic so
the two-year growth between 93 and 95
was a lot better than the two-year
growth act between 91 and 93 because I
attacked it a lot better so if you're
looking at your goals in 2023 or things
you're going to do better revisit the
past
because you got to know your past if you
know your [__] to know your
[__] future Public Enemy you
don't think I pay attention [__]
do you but no all jokes aside and that's
what I've done I do it all the time I
attack something it doesn't work out for
me how can I do it better boom and I do
it better for years I did this [__]
Kettlebell workout and I would walk
around my wrist with her from doing the
cleans and slamming your wrist then I
had to research the [__] knee surgery
and I'm like I can't do this no more but
I miss doing it I figured out a way how
to do it I lowered it down two [__]
weights and now I can at least do some
swings I could do some [__] cleans
I'm not looking to be Johnny [__]
Olympia I'm not looking to be you know
when the I'm just looking to be strong
and have
keep my dick hard you know when you're
turning when you're getting older you
want to keep that dick hard so you're
not going to look at me and go I can't
lift weights yes you can if you follow
Frank Zane on [__] Instagram he's 74.
this guy was Mr Olympia I don't know how
many times he's 74. he still looks like
a g he can't win no [__] bodybuilding
contest but he's healthy he does
everything with dumbbells and cables now
so I do what the [__] he does I'm not
Frank Zane but at least I'm keeping
myself alive and that's the most
important [__] thing guys it's 20 20
23 it's a whole new [__] year you're
not doing anything wrong just learn how
to attack right
and learn how to make you [__]
strikes count even more and that's what
I got to do at my age now so if it
worked for me
it's gonna work for you [__]
and that's
the Monday motivation January 9 2023
take that and put it in the bank
laughing gas is back in Jersey so don't
forget to contact my people at
[__] stonerclub.com
let them know you want some [__] I
think they got rainbow ruts at 38
percent
[__] bust out the Indians [__] suck
and that's it man we're back to [__]
normal laughing gases ripping and
rocking
uh it's the number one brand in [__]
California so if you get your hands on
it get your hands on I got one date left
and that's the 28th of January
and then we'll see where we're at the
book is officially [__] in tomorrow I
gotta okay the cover
and I gotta get an endorsement from my
man [__] uh TJ English
and then it's Tip Top [__]
Magoo guy so get ready April 23rd
and I'm better than ever I don't know
what's going to happen this year
but at least we'll keep this alive from
January we're only doing one podcast a
week
and in a couple weeks I'll let you know
what the [__] is going on I went to look
at three offices this week they're too
close to here are both dumps the one in
Red Bank was very nice and I really
wanted and I offered the guy a deposit
but
he doesn't know if the present
tenant is going to resign so he said
he'd let me know in the next 10 days but
at least some people called me back yeah
man I'm excited about this I want to do
something else I want to get out of my
house
this has been good but it's time to get
the [__] out of here she wants to move
into this room that's not happening I'm
gonna put a full-time office in here
like just a work office not like to do
videos and [__] like that so
that's the deal you bad [__]
it's the joint Monday the 9th of [__]
January get your [__] together I love
you [__] with all your luck my
all my heart do not forget we got TCU
against Georgia tonight
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors DraftKings tonight [__] sucker
all right you [__] thank you
for supporting me today thank you it's a
it's a great [__] day to be alive so
get your day started right the joint is
brought to you by DraftKings listen you
know Uncle Joey's go-to place for the
Wild Card round action is DraftKings
sports book the official sports betting
partner of the NFL the kick off the road
to Super Bowl 57 we're gonna get the
party started new customers bet five
dollars and get 200 and free bets
instantly plus all new existing
customers can get a no sweat bet each
day of the Wild Card round this weekend
just place an in the NFL better your
choice if it loses you get ten dollars
back with action this good why bet the
NFL playoffs anywhere else download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app today use code
Joey j-o-e-y new customers can bet five
dollars on the NFL and get 200 and free
bets instantly that's code Joey only at
DraftKings Sportsbook minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details draft download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app today listen
blue is here to make you sure you stay
hot in the bedroom I'm talking about
Bluetooth it's an online service that
delivers the same acting ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis only in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
just one two and be ready when the mood
is right listen this is the best out
there you sign up at Bluetooth you
consult with one of the licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your description in days
no lines no doctor's office no Pharmacy
waiting line all comes to your house and
it's easy and it's work Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA and they
sheep the script shipped discreetly if
you can perform for the extra conference
blue shoe can help that's right
Bluetooth for free when using promo code
Joey just pay five dollars for shipping
visit bluetooth.com for more safety
information and I want to thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring The Joint the
joint is also brought to you one of my
personal favorites I'm talking about
liquid IV no matter what your New Year's
goals are stay hydrated with liquid IV
it's easy to stay light hydrated also
you get five essential vitamins and it
hydrates you two times faster than water
alone with one stick of liquid IV that's
real use it first thing in the morning
like I do before a workout or on Long
flights you know me guys I'm a concord
grape pina colada fruit punch Cherry
type of guy these things are free from
gluten dairy and soy liquid IV contains
three times the electrolytes a
traditional sports drinks so grab your
liquid IV and bulk nationwide at Costco
they're great but I'm Gonna Get You 20
off when you shop at liquid iv.com use
code Joey again 20 off with Coach Joey
at liquid iv.com I want to thank liquid
IV I want to thank Bluetooth and I want
to thank DraftKings for making our
Mondays great stay black have a great
week and I'll see you [__] next
Monday tip top Magoo love you
[Music]
thank you